let inverted or upside down triangle x
be defined as x plus 1 over x let me
write that down inverted triangle x is
equal to x plus
1 over x for all non-zero integers x all
right
if inverted or upside down triangle x is
equal to t so if this whole thing is
equal to
t
whereas t is an integer which of the
following is a possible value of t so
let's think about this a little bit so
what you could try to do is you could
take each of these choices and
substitute it in for t
and then try to solve for x and see if
you can find x's that are integers but
instead of doing each of them one by one
let's just solve this let's just
rearrange this equation where we can
solve for x as a function of t and then
we could try the different t values out
then and see hey can we get can we get a
non-zero integer value for x
so if we take this and if we multiply
both sides by x we're going to get x
times x is x squared 1 over x times x is
1 and then t times x is t
x
now it looks like we have a quadratic we
could try to get into a standard form so
that we could try to factor it so let's
subtract tx from both sides and so i'm
gonna so if we subtract t x
from both sides
we are going to be left with on the left
hand side
x squared
minus t x
plus one
and that's going to be equal to zero
now this is interesting right over here
we have kind of a traditional quadratic
traditional quadratic equation right
over here and we just have to think
about well what for what values of t can
we actually factor this so that we could
integer solutions for x so actually
let's just write down all the options
over here so
if t is equal to 1 then this thing is
going to be x squared minus 1x we could
just say x squared minus x plus 1.
if t is equal to 0 then this middle term
disappears and you're just left with x
squared plus 1.
if t is equal to
if t is equal to negative 1 then this
thing becomes x squared
negative negative 1 so it's plus x plus
1.
if t is equal to negative 2 then you get
x squared
plus two x plus one
and then if t is equal to
running out of colors
if t is equal to negative three you have
x squared plus negative three negative
negative three so that's plus three x
plus 1. so which of these can you factor
well it might jump out at you that hey
this is a perfect square right over here
i can factor this one this is x
plus 1
times x plus 1. 1 plus 1 is 2 and 1
times 1 is 1 right over here so because
i can factor this i know i know that
this right over here is going to be my
answer if t is equal to negative 2
if t is equal to negative two then all
of this stuff boils down to that and we
could say that
x squared
minus t which is plus two
plus two x plus one is equal to zero the
left hand side is just x plus one
squared is equal to zero which means
that x plus one is equal to
zero which means that x would be equal
to
negative one so when t
when t is equal to negative two
that means that x is equal to negative
one and the negative one is a non-zero
integer you could look at these other
ones and you say well yeah this is very
hard to factor i need to take the
product of two numbers who's positive
one and their sum is negative one well i
can't think of
i can think of two i can't think of two
integers that would do that same thing
here x squared plus one how do i factor
that well i can't i there's no obvious
way at least in my brain of factoring
that same thing over here two numbers
whose product is one and whose sum is
positive one well i need two integers
and i can't think of any there and same
thing over here two numbers whose
product is one and whose sum is three
can't think of it but this one right
over here you can